I remember going into the shell and it
was just
shocker retirement there was about 80
inmates in the show
I was like a tennis
there was no space whatsoever
and I looked around that early eyes
looking up at me
I had to put that mask on again I was
satisfied
you know but it was often Brave at the
same time like a little bit of a Swagger
and I went and I got older to to sleep
in the corner next to this guy who'd
passed away
you've got a hard concrete floor there's
no mattresses you know I'm sleeping next
to a taller you know people living in
and out
I'm still suffering with Royals with
these drugs you know I'm usually on the
slight engines you can't really use
anything anyway you have to go so early
like the toilets put a blanket over you
I mean the toilets outside and the
compound but people were shell on the
buses did that they'll have makeshift
tents and they'd be selling their bodies
for sure that's